our equipment our software 3D printing
and CNC milling can take raw materials
blocks of metal things in their
primordial State and take them from
nothing and turn them into guns it might
seem strange that talking to a guy who
makes machines that manufacture
untraceable ghost guns makes me more
hopeful about the future but that's
exactly how I felt after our recent live
stream with Cody Wilson founder of
Defense distributed and creator of the
first ever 3D printed gun The Liberator
jump into the internet here and let's
let's have a party let's see if you can
if you can take these files off of the
internet Wilson's defense distributed
has a decade-long history of clashing
with government authorities and quite
often winning
since 2013 the state department tried
forcing the company to stop hosting gun
printing files on its Online Library
defcad by accusing them of violating an
arms export law
defense distributed filed a first and
second amendment case against them and
the government finally backed down in
2018. the Bureau of Alcohol Tobacco
firearms and explosives or ATF took aim
at so-called ghost guns last year with a
new rule that would have required gun
components known as 80 percent lower
receivers to Bear the same engraved
registration numbers as fully finished
guns which would have put most DIY kit
sellers out of business
defense distributed promptly responded
with the zero percent receiver a block
of aluminum that their ghost Gunner
machine could fashion into a gun
component challenging the feds to
regulate that
the ATF backed down from even publishing
the 80 receiver rule not only is it a
bad rule but they disable themselves in
federal court they have no power right
now to say what is and isn't a firearm
but what makes Wilson's project so vital
is that it's about more than Firearms
it's about demonstrating a method for
securing Liberty without asking
permission or as he put it in a 2013
South by Southwest talk shortly
following the launch of his Liberator
gun
practical Anarchy I'm interested in
demonstrating practical Anarchy one I
think the web is an anarchy I think the
web is a successful Anarchy you can buy
things on eBay you can buy things on
Amazon pseudonymouscommerce Works crypto
Commerce works and these principles are
bleeding back into the real world
through Technologies like
3D printing of course the internet has
changed since then big platforms have
grown more censorious with YouTube
removing the original Liberator video as
well as everything from DIY gun building
videos to biohacking tutorials to
disputes over pandemic policy and the
Twitter files have helped reveal the
degree to which government agents have
pressured platforms to remove speech
nonetheless Wilson thinks Freedom will
prevail online I think there's lots of
reason for optimism
I know everybody still wants the history
to have a meaning and a direction and
that there should be some World state to
satisfy us and it's you know Machines of
Loving Grace will
automate and give us luxury communist
conditions but you know do do I really
believe in that no I don't think it's
possible
um I just think it'll be a great mix
maybe it really will be like science
fiction high-tech low life you know like
incredible vast
interesting reaches of technical
progress with depressingly shallow and
animal-like living conditions I mean
maybe uh I guess these are all questions
of Aesthetics really and Aesthetics
become more important than philosophy so
I do think I still read the crypto
anarchist
you know books the the pirate Utopias
are these it's so breathtaking like the
Visions they had and so much of it came
true and of us the biggest part of that
is Bitcoin the forces of extreme
political centralization do remain a
threat to our freedom but major
technological Trends do seem to favor
decentralization and uncensorability in
the long run whether it's Cody Wilson's
decentralizing guns Bitcoin
decentralizing money or emerging social
media platforms like Nostra Mastodon and
blue sky decentralizing the architecture
of the web and granting individual users
more protection against the increasing
political pressure to de-platform
dissident speech and as Wilson points
out to us the large language model AI
chat Bots created by well-funded
companies like open Ai and Google are
now being open sourced and may present
yet another opportunity to disrupt an
otherwise steady March towards
authoritarianism we've done AI
experiments for years here we did text
models text-to-speech we got our own
chat Bots and stuff and if you are a
breakaway startup a company or any you
know you're interested in the
post-political and you want to be
commercial I think you need AI these
things are very powerful tools and there
seems to be just almost a total
alignment with using them in only one
direction to support the message you
know the narrative AI yeah let the AI be
a free thinker 30 billion parameter
model llm you can train on a laptop
right now I mean just to lower all these
things like every week you're seeing
these Innovations where I'm actually we
should be seeing all kinds of
interesting technical developments from
Libertarians and so-called capitalists
Cody Wilson isn't a spotless hero or a
personal role model as he himself admits
when discussing his guilty plea for
injury to a minor after paying for sex
with a woman he met on an adult hookup
app whom he says he didn't realize was
underage I want to choose not to make
excuses or see myself as some kind of
a victim or something so I will say you
know graciously I was I finally
completed my probation and my case was
dismissed if you want to do really
interesting and cool things you probably
should be above reproach or at least
attempting to be so that you don't
frustrate your message or you know don't
complicate your symbolic point so it was
a big education I'll say that Wilson
dubbed his first 3D gun the wiki weapon
his political hero Julian Assange also
got caught up in a sex crimes case which
led him to fleece Sweden seek asylum in
London's Ecuadorian Embassy and
ultimately end up in a London prison
where he lives to this day as he fights
U.S extradition for a dubious Espionage
charge that he's always claimed is the
real reason authorities wanted to detain
him in Sweden sanj Wikileaks that was
everything for me he was defeating the
payments blockade he was he was thumbing
his nose at the world hegemon at the
state department oh my God how is he
doing the internet's actually fulfilling
like a cyberpunk purpose this is crazy
and uh I was like whatever I'm doing is
nothing what he's doing
this whatever this is and so that's I
began to study this uh the cypherpunks
and the literature of join assange's
movement moment and um that's what put
me on on the path to what we did we
don't need to whitewash the personal
lives or fully embrace the politics of
complicated figures like Assange or Cody
Wilson to recognize the fundamental
importance of their shared mission to
put Vital Information and tools in the
hands of free and peaceful people my
gift is always like a Defiance to power
in the terms of power except for itself
challenging power to be real or to
imminentize itself you know and saying
like I don't believe that you're real
I've just been trying to use gojard's
fatal strategies and theories of games
and theories of Seduction trying to
infuse some of those rules into our
projects and address a certain audience
of power and invite that power to
exhaust itself Etc I could keep going
all day
[Music]
hey thanks for watching and excerpt from
our conversation with Cody Wilson you
can watch the full conversation right
here or another clip from that
conversation right here and tune in next
Thursday at 1 pm Eastern for another
reason live stream